MALE SPEAKER: Good.
Hello.
Give me a cheer.
[CHEERING]
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Good.
Thank you so much for coming
to Talks at Google today.
I'm very pleased to
introduce Simon Bradley.
Simon is joint editor of
the celebrated "Pevsner
Architectural Guide" to which
he has contributed a number
of notable revised volumes.
He started trainspotting
age 11, and his
is interest in railways
has broadened and endured.
He's the author of "St. Pancras"
Station, and lives in London.
Please, join me in giving
Simon a huge round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
SIMON BRADLEY: Well, thank you,
and thank you all for coming.
St. Pancras Station, I am going
to start here, because that's
what you see you.
What you are seeing is
the view from the top
of that very tall train
shed, the covered area where
the trains come in and out,
a great Victorian building
of the 1860s.
The gasometer there, the gas
holder is a bit of a giveaway.
And I show you
this now lost view,
because this is where they built
the Eurostar extension, just
to perhaps introduce a sense of
the railways as a world apart.
You know, here's a technology,
which when it was first built
was really still
quite new, the 1860s.
The first mature railways start
in the 1830s, or just before.
And it has to make
up its own rules.
It's a system.
It's a network, and it's
invented in Britain.
So a great many of
the innovations,
a great many of the
conventions, the language,
vocabulary-- it's
all starting here.
And railways are
interesting, anyway, really,
if you're interested
in railways.
But if you're going to
get seriously interested,
this really is the best country
to do it, because for reasons
that Ill come on to, but the
diversity and the complexity,
but also the sense of them as
a site of constant innovation
and they're a combination
of very old and very new
sometimes.
It's a quite
complicated picture.
But I've been
thinking about Google,
and thinking about information,
and thinking about complexity
and all of those things
which I'm sure many of you
are working with all the time.
This is how to do things before
you haven't got software.
These are railway tickets, as
I'm sure you saw straight away.
But they're of a
very specific type.
These were the
standard type which
were in use into the one 1980s.
They finally disappeared
into the 1990s.
They were invented in 1838
in a weird, one-off way.
The young railways drew
in all sorts of people
from all walks of life.
You couldn't be an apprentice
to them or anything,
because they were new.
They had to find
people, able people.
And an unsuccessful
cabinet maker from Carlisle
called Thomas
Edmondson got a job
at one of the stations
on the Newcastle
and Carlisle railway, one
of the very early lines.
It was built completely
isolated from anything else
at that time.
And in his spare
moments, he began
to think about how they
could improve the ticketing.
Up to that point, tickets were
written out by hand, largely.
You went in, and the booking
office was called the booking
office because you
booked your journey,
and a clerk would have
some sort of printed form,
but he would write them out.
And this was very laborious
and also rather open to abuse.
He could write one
thing in the book,
and he could issue the ticket.
He could take money,
and he could fiddle it.
There was no record, no easy
way of keeping a record.
So as well as being
time consuming and slow,
it was also leaky.
So Edmondson
thought, well, if you
print the tickets in
advance, but also you number
them in advance, then you
don't need to keep a record.
You don't need to
account for it.
The tickets themselves
are your record.
He more or less made
this all himself at home,
a series of cylinders,
metal cylinders
with a spring at the bottom.
It pushed the tickets up.
You take the top ticket out.
It's got a number on.
You keep taking the tickets,
and the number remaining
gives you, by
subtraction, if you like,
the number that you sold.
And someone can
come along and check
that the amount of
money you've got,
because everyone's
paying by cash,
is equal to the number
of tickets sold.
So this is a very
clever system, and he
tries to persuade his
superiors to adopt it.
And they're not very
interested, but then
he just starts hawking it
around other companies,
and within a couple of years,
he's got his own business.
He's licensing his
system to other railways,
and it conquers all
the other lines.
And they're not very big.
If you're a bit older, you
probably remember these things.
They're about one inch by
two, quite easy to lose.
And the convention
until fairly recently,
coming into Victoria into
the early 70s, I think,
was that the ticket
collector would tear it.
If you had a return ticket,
he'd tear it in half
and give you back
the other half.
So people talked
about the return half.
So the half ticket,
one inch square,
was even easier to lose.
And you can imagine music
or jokes and things about,
I've lost me return half.
You were stranded, or you had
to buy another ticket, which
would be expensive.
So there's the Edmondson System.
And what Edmondson
didn't anticipate,
and what nobody
anticipated, was what
was going to happen when
all these railways joined
up, and from a series of
separate lines became a system
or a network.
And that meant you
could travel through,
but you were travelling through
from the territory of one
company to another.
You might be travelling through
several company territories.
You might be traveling
or sending goods
through several company
territories as well.
I won't talk much about
goods and freight,
but they're at least as
important as the passengers
in terms of the
business side of things.
So what happens then is
that in the Midlands,
where lines first
really start coalescing,
a few companies get together,
and they set up what's
called a railway clearinghouse.
It's a place where all
the costs and income
can be assessed and
sorted out, usually
on the basis of mileage.
So this requires a
very complicated series
of calculations.
You have to work out exactly
how long all the lines are,
and agree with one another
about how long the lines are,
apportion a charge for carrying
a person, a half fare, parcels,
freight, all the rest of
it, pass your records on.
So the photograph you see-- this
is the railway clearinghouse
in about 1930, I suppose.
It's not a very well
recorded building at all.
There are very few photographs
of what actually went on there.
But what the women
there are doing--
it does seem to be almost
entirely women-- they've
got on the table
in front of them
huge bundles of these Edmondson
tickets, because the tickets
themselves then became, if you
like, the information, what
was passed on.
The tickets became
their own receipts,
their own counterfoils.
And so they're checking.
They're number crunching, I
think before anything even
like an adding machine.
You certainly can't see one.
Of course electronic media
can do more and more things
all the time, but
there's something awe
inspiring about the complexity
and the size and scale of what
the railways were
doing through entirely
old-fashioned pen and
paper sort of media,
again within living memory.
It still exists, the
railway clearinghouse,
the buildings there.
It's like an enormous and very,
very plain Georgian terrace
somewhere north
of Euston station.
You could be
mistaken for thinking
it had been a box factory
or something like that.
But it grew and grew,
because eventually
all the British companies,
except for a few very small
ones, all came onside.
So now back to the origins.
This is the Liverpool
and Manchester Railway.
It opened in 8:30, the first
mature passenger railway.
There were other ways
of travelling by train,
behind a horse, horse
drawn vehicles on rail,
things like that.
But this is the first one
that had publicly advertised,
timetabled steam-hauled
trains, and was conceived
as such from the beginning.
And this introduces
the question of class.
Then there was first,
second, and third class.
And it doesn't
take much thinking
to see which ones they are.
The upper train is
all first class.
They had separate first
class trains originally.
And the carriages looked
like what they actually were,
which is stagecoach bodies.
Each carriage there is made up
of effectively three stagecoach
or private road carriage bodies.
That's how they were
built. They were
built by the same people who
were building the stagecoaches,
because there wasn't suddenly
a new industry of railway
carriage building.
You just found someone who would
build these things for you.
And then right at
the very back, you
see what's called
a carriage truck.
It's a flat wagon onto which
you could drive your carriage
if you happen to
be wealthy enough
to have your own carriage.
So people having done that, they
would actually travel in them.
And it sounds a bit outlandish,
and it was not entirely safe,
because you would get cinders
from the locomotive falling
on you and things like that,
and it was certainly exposed.
But the idea came back
when the Eurostar trains
started running.
If you've ever done it,
you drive your vehicle
into a covered
wagon, in this case,
and you go through the
tunnel, and you come out
on the other side.
So it's an idea that
came, went, and then
has come back again in
a very specific way.
Below that, second class and
a version of third class,
I think, we've got
more or less exposed.
As it settled down, eventually,
third class-- and we'll
see some early examples later--
were actually completely open.
They were almost like cattle
trucks without roofs, at least
in the early years
of the railway.
So you're creating a
series of social spaces,
because stagecoaches
were social spaces too.
But more people are traveling,
and they're travelling further,
and the experience of the
chance to travel is moving down
the social scale,
because it's cheaper.
So this is first class.
This is first class in 1855.
A painting called "First
Class, the Meeting."
And I show it because it gives
the idea of close confinement
with strangers and
at its loveliest.
Because what's happening
here is the young man--
you can see he's
an army officer.
He's got his sword-- is meeting
the thoroughly respectable
gentleman, a papa, or guardian,
or an uncle, or something,
and the young lady
who is with him,
and they're falling in love.
And it was all spelled out.
But he's sitting
safely between them.
He's earnest, and
obviously a good sort,
and she's obviously
a good sort too,
because she's rather
modest and shy.
But all these details matter.
There was a previous
version of this painting
shown at the Royal
Academy the year
before with the same title.
And the old gentleman is
sitting in the corner seat,
and he's fallen asleep.
And the young lady is
looking a bit less shy.
And the young gentleman,
he's not an army officer.
He's a fisherman.
He's out.
He's on the pull, you might say.
And people thought this
painting was rather immoral.
So this gives you a
sense of the slightly
stuffy and preposterous ways
in which the Victorians could
moralize their art.
Art had to be improving,
or it had to be decorous.
But it's also a precious
view of something
which wasn't very well recorded
at the time-- the interior
of a railway compartment, a
first class rather compartment,
as they reached
their early maturity.
So you see lots of plush,
lots of upholstery.
It's a luxurious space.
Difficult to keep clean,
but it had lots of labor
to try and do it.
There are things,
slightly mysterious things
known as grommets hanging
on the upright mullian thing
by the window.
These were to help
you in and out.
You grabbed on to them, or you
could rest your arm in them
if your arm got
tired apparently.
That sounds more like a way of
cutting off your circulation.
And these lingered until
the early 20th century.
The thing above the
old gentleman's head,
that's his hat.
They had straps or strings
drawn across the roofs
of the carriages for
gentlemen's hats.
Because hats were all
the stovepipe kind then.
And you turned them upside
down, and you fitted them in.
And you didn't tread on
them, or knock them over,
because they were both
fragile and expensive.
Now down to second class.
This is about 1890,
so rather less idyllic
and probably a rather
more realistic view.
Well, yes the recent
coinage manspreading,
there's definitely some
manspreading going on here.
Also, there's smoking.
You couldn't smoke in
early railway carriages,
but as more and more
people in the wider world
started smoking-- cigarettes
came in, for instance,
in the 1850s-- and it got very
hard to police, one reason
being that you couldn't walk up
and down the train checking who
was smoking, because the
trains were still made up
of these separate compartments.
So once you were in
your compartment,
that was your space until you
got the chance to get out.
And that might be for
hours, and hours, and hours.
So you had to
think about how you
dealt with lavatories,
how you dealt
with refreshments and food.
There's a lot about
this in the book,
and I won't go on about it.
But gradually we get
the modern joined up
train with a carriage, with a
corridor, or the connections
between the carriages.
And on a long
distance journey, you
might also have a buffet
car, a restaurant car,
or something like that.
So close confinement
with strangers.
Well, there's something
edgy about it, potentially.
And worse than that, it was
something dangerous, and very
occasionally something fatal.
This is from a rather
disreputable publication
called "The Illustrated
Police News," which
was just true crime stuff.
So very cheaply produced
commercial artists
summing up scenes from the
most lurid and exciting crime
stories.
And this was its
front page story.
This was the Balcombe
Tunnel Murder.
Anyone come in from
Brighton or come
through the Balcombe Tunnel?
If you come that
way, then you're
passing through the site
of Britain's second railway
murder, by which
I mean an attack
on a stranger in a train.
There was an unsuccessful
would-be actor.
You see his rather unimpressive
profile at the bottom.
And anxious for more money to
keep up his flash appearance,
he attacked a banker,
stockbroker in the compartment
and robbed him of his
gold watch and money,
threw him out, was
caught and then escaped.
The police didn't really
distinguish themselves.
He was being watched in a house,
but they didn't watch the back,
so he just escaped
out of the back.
Then they found him.
He went to ground
somewhere in London,
and they found him in his
lodgings with false whiskers
and things from his
theatrical friends,
trying to disguise himself.
But it was no good, and
he was eventually hanged.
So moving on from that
model of the compartment,
this is an early central
gangway type carriage.
This is from the Great
Western Railway in the 1930s.
And this type was
known well before then,
but the British system for
long distance journeys,
the preferred form
remained the kind
with a corridor down one side
and a series of compartments
with sliding doors
opening off it.
These were around on our system
until about 10 years ago,
and going back
more like 15 years,
you start to find
them especially
on Southern Electric, where
the first class remained
of that type.
They become more common.
So you probably will have
encountered some of these.
Latterly, it tended
to be first class that
had their compartments, and
second class that was all open.
But now even first
class is open.
And whenever they
did tests, whenever
they did a public
survey, everyone
preferred the compartment type.
There was something about
the early travelling
in compartments and getting
used to the idea that,
for all its disadvantages in
terms of being stuck in one
space, and the difficulty
of moving through the train,
that people preferred it.
But finally the
railways persuaded us
that we should move into the
more space efficient kind,
or would rather stop
giving us the choice.
And now pretty well
everyone travels
in something rather
more like, if you like,
the body of an airliner.
And as we're on so close to
Victoria and Southern Electric
territory, I couldn't resist
showing this-- the double deck
train.
This is it on the 1st of
November 1949 on a trial trip.
Everyone looks a
bit apprehensive,
and it entered service
the following day.
There were only ever eight of
these carriages, two four car
units.
And they worked out of Charing
Cross and Cannon Street
on the Dartford Loop.
And they were an attempt
to fit more people in.
it's a standard dilemma of
overcrowded trains in the rush
hour.
The idea being that you
could put people on top,
and you get more space.
So there are little
staircases in there.
They weren't a success.
One reason is they
were just too cramped.
There's a thing called a loading
gauge, which is a railway way
term for how big you
can make your vehicles,
carriages, locomotives
before they start
hitting things, the
clearances around the tunnels,
and the platforms, and the
buildings, and all of that,
and also the other tracks.
It didn't really allow
British trains ever
to push to that
double deck stage,
but they're relatively
common on the continents
and in other countries.
You do find these double deck,
especially commuter carriages,
but it didn't quite work here.
So now leaving the
train and moving
into the network, the
infrastructure, the buildings--
all of those things.
I'll show a few views
of railway stations.
This is the very first
Euston Station, 1837.
So only just
Victorian, if you like.
That's when Queen Victoria
comes to the throne.
So railways are a
pre-Victorian invention
in this country, at least.
And there you can see,
lined up, those are some
opened third class carriages.
So imagine I'm in 1837.
All you could do was
go to Birmingham,
but that's still a long way
and took you several hours,
because the train would
go at a maximum maybe 30,
40 miles an hour
if you were lucky.
But open carriages are
running to Scotland
by the time that they're
finally put a stop to,
because the government
starts steering
the quality of what we don't
might call the passenger
experience.
They insist on certain
minimum standards.
So this is the carriages.
The Space.
It's under, it's the absolute
novelty of all of this.
You have to think there's
nothing like this building that
had existed 10 years before.
It's using all the
new technologies,
using mass production
of cast iron.
And that gives you those
columns, and the arches
between, and the rather spidery
network of braces and hangers
which are sitting underneath
the roof and the framing
of the roof too.
The roof itself has is wooden
with a few glass windows.
This is quite a common
early type of railway train
shed, as we call them, the
shelter for the trains.
Not so common now, because
most of them have gone,
but actually if you go
to Dublin where there's
been much less
pressure to rebuild
and much less expansion,
several of the railway termini
there are 1840s
buildings, and they still
have train sheds of just
this type, even down
to those rather elegant
arches, in the space
between the arch in the
horizontal above it,
those diminishing circles.
You see that pattern.
It was a way of giving lightness
and strength to something,
but also in aesthetically
pleasing way,
not quite like fractal,
but the same shape,
but diminishing in
size and in sequence.
Now we jump forward, because
again, this is changing.
This is all changing
very quickly,
and it's getting
bigger very quickly.
And they're realizing
not quite that they've
created a monster that
they can't control,
but that the growing lad
is going to require rather
more by way of bigger clothes
and all the rest of it
for his future prosperity.
So this is Paddington
in the 1850s.
It's an 1860s image
of Paddington,
and Paddington is
built in the 1850s.
It's a famous painting, or
was famous in its day, called
"The Railway Station."
And it shows you every type and
condition of person all about
to travel on the train.
It's full of incident.
There's plainclothes
policemen arresting
a pickpocket in one corner.
You can see who's
going off to the races.
You can see who's respectable
and not quite so respectable,
the different classes and types.
Because again, this is the
railways as a social condenser,
or a place where people come
into close proximity on much
more equal terms than
they might have expected.
The duke and the peasant are
rubbing shoulders briefly,
and they're both customers
of the Great Western Railway,
even if they're going to
be travelling in different
carriages.
You see also that luggage
was put on top early on,
and then they'd put a tarpaulin
over it in case it rained.
This arrangement didn't last.
They started having separate
guards vans, usually, which
would take your baggage for
you, and then would put it out
at the correct station, so it
had to be correctly labeled.
More like the airline model.
You did it with
your big luggage.
You didn't travel with it.
You couldn't try and take
it into the carriage.
There just wasn't the room.
But look at that roof up above.
Now we've got something
arched, and the arch form
gives you more potential
to push the dimensions.
So Paddington has got
three parallel arch spans,
and they're wider than
the Euston ones, which
were just a simple up
and down ridged roof.
I could go on and
on about all this,
because the first
railway book I wrote
was a little monograph
on St. Pancras Station.
And St. Pancras where
the climax comes,
because that was 245, 246 feet
across, over 100 feet high.
I have to get the exact
metric equivalents,
but that was the widest single
span structure in the world.
And it kept that
record for 20 years.
So again, it's the railway
forcing innovation and pushing
technology to its limit.
So it's an exciting story.
Up until about 1880, 1900,
quite a few major themes
in the roadway are just
about bigger, faster, better.
And faster, obviously,
goes on into our own times.
So Paddington Station,
well, one more image.
Another instance of
railways driving forward
without even really planning
or expecting to do so.
Hotels, they don't
start building hotels,
but then they think, well,
we've got a captive market.
People are going to
want to travel early.
arrive late at night.
How nice to have a hotel
ready and waiting for them?
Or, looking at it another way,
why should all this custom
go to people who aren't
part of our company?
So stations start being
planned with hotels,
and Paddington is
one of the earliest.
That hotel is still there.
The image is one of the little
pictures, carriage pictures,
that used to be put up in
those railway compartments.
So if the railway is
advertising itself, if you like.
to its passengers.
They weren't all adverts.
Sometimes, they were
just pretty views.
But then again, the
pretty views were
of places you could
go to on the railways.
And these carriage pictures
would sit there for decades.
There were still Edwardian
Victorian ones knocking around
in the system in the '50s.
And I think that's
something that's
been lost from the
system now, the sense
of the very old stuff still
working alongside the very new.
You have to look at
the buildings now
to get that sense of the
depth of historical time.
And the genius behind the
Great Western was Brunel.
And Brunel's a rather
culty figure now,
and I think he fits a
certain modern idea of what
a genius and
innovator should be,
because he's a
bit of a maverick.
He's a bit of an outsider.
He cuts a dash.
You can probably visualize him
with his hat and his cigar.
And he forces his ideas through.
People think the ideas
won't work, and they will.
Well, a great deal
of this is true.
And he was a genius, and
he was a magnetic figure.
And we're lucky to have
him, or have had him.
But it didn't all
work quite as planned.
So this image, it's
called "Glocester,
the Change of Gauge."
And the point being that
the original railways,
the first railways
built in this country
and then taken around the world,
were to the same size-- 4 feet
8 and 1/2 inches
between the rails.
So that's the gauge,
as the term goes.
So you can take a
train from Britain,
and you can run it all the
way across the continent.
You can run it all the way
from the top of the Americas
down to the bottom.
There are parts of the world
where the gauge is different.
India is one.
Russia is another.
But as a rule, there is
what's called standard gauge.
It's there in Australia.
It's there in New Zealand.
It's the same here.
And that's not just because
of Britain being the model.
It's partly that.
But it's for obvious reasons
of being able to run through.
Brunel, before this had become
quite so clear as it rapidly
did become, looked
at the system,
and thought he was going to redo
it from scratch, because that's
how he liked to work.
So he thought, this
gauge is too small.
Make it wider.
Make it half as wide again.
Seven foot and one fourth
inch, in this instance.
Then you could have
more stable trains.
You can have trains that
will therefore run faster.
Advantages all around-- bigger
and bigger carrying capacity
you'll need fewer carriages and
wagons to carry the same stuff.
It all worked perfectly
except for the question
of what happens when you have to
carry stuff across the country.
Going from London
to Bristol and back,
the original Great Western,
it was a better railway.
It smoother, faster,
all of those things.
But if you wanted to take your
produce from the west country
up to the north or vice
versa, then everything
had to be taken off the wagons
and put onto other wagons.
And this was extremely
expensive and inconvenient.
Passengers, not quite
so bad, because people
were used to
changing trains, used
to having their luggage
taken off one train
and put on another.
But goods don't walk
across platforms.
You've got to do it yourself.
So there was a
great deal of this.
And what happened
as a compromise
was that we had what
was called mixed gauge.
You would have tracks
with both widths
so you could run
both kinds of train.
And then gradually after that,
the broad gauge withered away.
And it was a long time dying.
The last broad gauge
trains ran in the 1890s.
And they were
extraordinary things,
great, big, broad,
squat-looking locomotives.
Very stable.
Stability was an
early preoccupation
before they'd worked out that
the better you made the track,
the faster you could run trains
and still keep them stable.
So in a sense, Brunel was
trying to solve a problem that
rapidly didn't exist.
And it gets stranger.
This is the only appearance of
the word cyberpunk in my book,
because the atmospheric railway
is so unearthly, and weird,
and ghostly.
Brunel didn't invent it.
I'll explain the
principle first.
Rather than having a locomotive
burning coal, generating steam,
pulling the train,
the idea was that you
would take that power
generating function
and just put it to one side.
You'd build a pumping station.
There, the steam is generated.
The engine goes up
and down, and you
pump air out of a big
cast iron pipe that
runs down the middle of
the rails, as you see.
This is all
pre-photography, so this
is a very good reconstruction
drawing from about 20
years ago, I think.
And then the train has a
thing like a piston inside.
And on top of the
cast iron pipe,
there's a flap
which is sealable.
And as the air is pulled out,
pumped out, I should say,
of the pipe, the
train is drawn along.
And then you can brake the
train by releasing the vacuum
in the pipe and so on.
So this actually did
work, but it worked
in only very limited ways.
So the first successful use of
it is a little line in Dublin,
and it just goes up and down.
It goes up every half
hour or something,
and as you keep pumping,
the vacuum is recreated.
And you can run it
back down by gravity,
because it's all on a slope.
So that's a good model.
And they try and make it work
in the London to Croydon Line.
Again, we're in the
Victoria territory.
And they almost make it
work, but all the things
that don't work-- what
happens when two lines meet?
What do your pipes do?
They had to build a flyover.
It was first railway flyover
to cross from one line
to the other, because these
lines were effectively
self-contained.
How do you reverse?
What happens if one pumping
station breaks down?
So they could just
about make it work.
And Brunel implemented
it on a huge scale
on the line down
in the south Devon.
You may remember
where the sea broke
through the dawlish
a winter or so ago,
and severed the
line for a while?
Well, that's the place.
Other things that went
wrong-- the sea air
was much more damaging to
the technology of the pipe
than it had been further inland.
There's a legend, which I think
must have some basis in truth,
that the sealant of the slot
along the top of the pipe,
which was made of
leather, greased leather,
that rats came and ate it.
That wasn't the main
fault. The main fault
was it got too brittle and hard.
But you're going to
get rats, aren't you?
And they're going to
have a good old nibble
if they get the chance.
So this thing cost a fortune.
Brunel invested a
lot of money in it
himself, because that
division between the engineer
and the capital raising
function was blurred back then.
You would invest in
your own projects.
You had a stake in them.
And that was meant to
create confidence too.
But eventually they gave up.
So it worked.
It worked for a few
weeks, or a few months.
It half worked.
But it was a terrible idea,
and Brunel had his good friend
but often friendly
rival Robert Stephenson,
son of George Stephenson,
telling him so.
It wasn't for the
want of telling.
So this is Brunel, if you
like, at his most dedicated,
and dogged, and innovative,
but also just completely,
completely wrong.
But it's a wonderful story.
So now moving away, and
moving closer to our own time,
I'll just say something
about modernization, or what
actually we now call branding.
In the '50,s mid-50s,
British Rail said, right,
we're going to modernize.
We're going to have
electric and diesel trains.
And a lot of the ways in
which that was planned
were misconceived, because they
couldn't anticipate the effect,
especially of road transport,
both for passengers
and for freight.
So then there was a convulsion
in the early '60s, mid-60s,
with the Beeching cuts,
as well remembered.
A lot of lines, rural
lines, less used lines
were closed down.
But the positive side
of that was an attempt
to modernize their own
[INAUDIBLE] branch.
And that meant thinking
about how it looked.
That meant, for the
first time really,
thinking about railways
as a national brand.
So that was when British
Railways became British Rail.
That was when the long
familiar but now vanished
colors of blue
and white, or just
all blue for the carriages,
came in with the yellow ends.
So you see an early version
of that there in this model.
And that was where the
double arrow sign came in.
It was one of about 60 or 80
designs supplied by the design
research unit, which was a very
innovative all purpose design
house.
It was designed by a
21-year-old who's still around,
Michael Jerry Barney.
And he just happened to
come up with the best idea.
It was like in an
advertising agency,
the young cub gets the
best idea sort of story.
And you should see
some of the others.
They're so fussy and confusing.
But the idea of the two
trains passing, or the speed,
or something.
Anyway, it whatever
it was, that took.
And there you see it.
And there's Tamworth
Station in Staffordshire,
which was being rebuilt as part
of an electrification scheme
going up to the north.
So this is a whole new railway.
Everything is new except
for the very line itself.
The route itself is a
very early Victorian line,
but everything else is new--
trains, track, electrification,
architecture, signage, the lot.
And there is a design guide,
which with amazing control
freakery, showed you exactly how
the lettering should be done,
the intervals between the
lettering, how to proportion,
everything aligned,
everything [INAUDIBLE].
It's a rather uptight,
modernist designers' paradise,
this sense that
everything's on the grid.
Everything is designed.
But it was a very,
very good design.
And I learned quite late
in writing the book in time
to put it in that the
Danish state railways liked
the look, the corporate
image of British Rail
so much that they just
bought it, basically.
I haven't been to
Denmark, and I don't
know how far the stations still
have all the same signage,
but the photographs of Danish
railways in the 70s, everything
just looks like British
Rail signage used to,
but with those Danish
diacritical marks
and sort of funny signs
on the letters and things.
But it must be
the only instance,
I think, of Scandinavian
public design
copying British public
design, because normally it's
always going the other way.
So there-- pride
in British Rail.
If you've been at
the station in 1948,
you might have seen
my father trying
to find a pair of binoculars
that he'd just been
given by a well-off auntie.
Binoculars were an even more
expensive thing than now.
Because he'd gone
there trainspotting.
He had come from
Birmingham, but Tamworth
was where you saw faster,
better trains, expresses.
And some bastard had
stolen his binoculars.
And he never got them back, and
he never dared tell his auntie.
But I've talked finally
about the trainspotting
side, or the enthusiasm side.
I'm used to just people
kind of collapsing
the enthusiast-- the historian
even-- into the trainspotter.
But I don't really mind, because
I was a trainspotter too.
And in the '40s and
'50s, and into the '60s,
it wasn't a marginal thing.
This is the what actually
sometimes gets forgotten.
It was an absolutely ordinary
common boyhood thing, really.
Boyhood and adolescence.
It was like an interest
in anything else
you might be interested
in at that age.
And it was free,
or cheap anyway.
You bought a little book,
you ticked off the numbers.
You did with your friends.
It was a social activity.
So that's the first proper
trainspotters handbook in 1943.
So all the signs of the
generosity of certain sorts
of wartime censorship.
A private publisher
published the details
of all Britain's
locomotives on their numbers
in the midst of the
war, while I don't
suppose on the other side they
thought this information was
for general circulation.
It might have been
militarily sensitive.
And that's Newcastle
Central Station.
And in fact, by the age of 15
the family moved back north.
And so the lads on the right
are in the uniform of my school,
the Royal Grammar School.
So that gives you an idea of it
being a social thing, I think.
This isn't some kind of
sad loner with his anorak
and thermos flask.
There are lots of these boys.
They're having fun.
They're together.
No they're [INAUDIBLE] pushing
and shoving and things.
We know this because
the reason they
were on the castle-- that's
the great castle of Newcastle
itself-- was that
they'd all been
banned from the station
for misbehavior.
So the station was
closed to trainspotters.
Exactly the same thing
happened at Tamworth.
Tamworth was the first
station closed trainspotters,
because they were rushing
up and down the platforms
and generally
getting in the way.
So that was probably when it
became a national phenomenon.
And tracked the story through
the national newspapers.
The word trainspotter first
appears around 1947, '48,
with other variants
of the same name.
And it's a youth culture.
It comes up from below.
No one's really encouraging
it apart from a few publishers
who are profiting from it.
The railways are of
two minds about it,
because they can be
a damned nuisance.
But gradually, they come
to an accommodation.
And finally, what came out
of that great convulsive
modernization, I
think more drastic
than that in any other
country, steam disappears
far quicker than people expect.
Masses of lines
are closed, which
people thought and expected
were going to stay open.
There's this big redesign.
Suddenly, everything
looks different.
Everything is all
modernist, and it had
been a bit more traditional.
And so this creates
a gigantic nostalgia
among the generation who
were spotters, especially
and a desire to save things.
And what starts as little
local ventures here
and there gradually becomes
a national movement.
And now you can travel.
You can travel back in time.
This is the Mid Hants
Railway down in Hampshire,
which aims at just that
period, really-- '50s and '60s.
So there you see
locomotives of the time,
and carriages and the
livery of that time,
and engine shed
built from scratch.
It's on a closed down line.
It's on one of the lines that
fell victim to Dr. Beeching.
And as you probably know,
there are dozens and dozens
of these lines, some of them
are excellent, some of them
not quite so good.
If you're curious and
you've never been to one,
I recommend you start
with the Blue Bell Railway
down in Sussex.
Easy, easy access from
Victoria and a connection
to the main line.
That was the first
one to take over
a disused part of
the main network,
and that's been running
now for 55 years.
So this is part of the British
way of life, you might say.
But there's always something
distant as well about the past
that you can't capture.
So I'm going to end with an
image which I think conveys
that quite well.
These are men of the Lancashire
and Yorkshire Railway
in about 1910,
demonstrating with
wonderful unselfconsciousness
some of the hand signals used
when shunting.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I thought
trainspotting
was almost an extension of
collecting [INAUDIBLE] cards.
It's ticking off--
SIMON BRADLEY: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And wanting to
collect the whole set.
SIMON BRADLEY: Yeah.
It's the collecting
instinct, but there was also
the excitement of the
unpredictability of it.
And also, it was a bit edgy, and
that always sounds ridiculous,
but standing on a
platform, that's easy.
Anyone can do that.
But what you want to do is get
to where the best trains are.
And that ultimately,
probably is going
to mean trespassing, or at
least you try and talk your way
into places.
So places where
there were engine
sheds, locomotive sheds, that
was where you wanted to be,
because then you could
just hoover the things up.
And if you couldn't get
in by and arranged visit,
you might just of
go around anyway.
And you did get caught, and you
did get thrown out sometimes,
and threatened to
have your name taken.
MALE SPEAKER: Any questions?
Any questions?
Yes, and if you could
repeat the question back.
AUDIENCE: What
lessons from history
could improve the state
of the railways today?
And the example I would give
is that we had had either wider
gauge from the
beginning, so if we
had gone from being able
to run faster trains,
or if we were able to, you
mentioned clearances before,
if you could just lower
all the lines two feet
and run [INAUDIBLE]
trains, for example.
Are there any of
these things that you
think aren't part
of current policy,
but could be implemented today?
SIMON BRADLEY: Well,
lessons from history,
this gets a bit
political, I suppose,
because the railways
were nationalized.
And then they were privatized.
And the nationalized
system, well this
is complicated territory.
But you can certainly
point to the figure
that British Rail had as a
subsidy in its latter day
existence, which is
about 1 billion a year.
And it was run on a shoestring,
but it was lean and efficient,
and it knew what it did well.
And it knew what it would do if
it had a bit more money, more
electrification especially,
reopening some old lines,
things like that.
The privatized system now has a
subsidy of about 4.55 billion,
but it has twice
as many passengers.
But twice as many
passengers doesn't always
mean that your line's
going to get cheaper
to run, but to be honest,
if your turnover doubles
and your fares go massively up,
you should be able to do that.
So we now have a system
which is more expensive,
has a much higher turnover,
and also requires more subsidy.
And the reason, frankly, is
the way it was privatized.
It was Christian Wolmar,
the writer on railways
and transport, said that it
took a single system that
ran at a modest subsidy, and
broke it up into about 100
companies, every
single one of which
was required to show a profit.
So how do you do that?
And the answer is,
there are subsidies
fed in all sorts of ways,
including that Network Rail,
the publicly owned
body that owns
the track and the stations,
just racks up huge, huge debts.
So that's got to 34 billion.
And then when the EU
said that this is a con.
You're using this to keep
it off the balance sheet,
because this is part of the
national debt, that's now been
added to the national debt.
So that's the privatized
system behind the sort
of headline figures.
And it's just amazes
me that these, frankly,
rather scandalous arrangements
aren't that well known.
So I would bring more
of it, as much of it
as you can back into
public ownership
or public-private partnership.
And it's heartening in a modest
way with the overground system,
because those take lines which
were previously franchised out
to various operators, like the
North London Line, North London
Link.
And they then become part
of the transport for London.
And the service always
improves, and it always
becomes more efficient, but it's
no longer having to pay out.
So there we are-- politics.
AUDIENCE: I would
follow that up just
to ask that if it's a
privatisation or a bringing
it all back under
one roof happened,
if you were running
that group, what
would be the first
things you might change,
maybe more again from the
technical perspective in terms
of being able to do more
now with what you now
have brought together?
SIMON BRADLEY: I
think electrification
is the one that does work,
and was very pleased that just
yesterday was it?
That the pause, as it was called
on some of the electrification
projects on the main lines,
that's been unpaused.
I don't think people in
the industry expected
that to happen. they thought
it might drift and drift
for years, but a lot of
that work had started.
So before too long, you'll be
able to go to major cities--
Cardiff, Bristol, that
was already happening,
but Sheffield, Nottingham, and
really just do more of that,
actually.
Not every line, because it
doesn't pay for smaller lines,
but you could electrify
up to Aberdeen.
That would be good.
You could electrify
down to Plymouth.
That would be good.
There's quite a lot still to
do, and Britain's massively
behind the continent in how
far the lines are electrified.
MALE SPEAKER: Round to the back.
AUDIENCE: So this follows
on quite well from that.
What do you of
[INAUDIBLE] Good idea?
Bad idea?
More important, less important
than electrification?
SIMON BRADLEY: Yeah,
HS2, what do I think?
Well, slightly mixed feelings.
Partly because there
are existing lines
which could be delivered
by electrification
and other relatively
modest improvements,
could deliver a lot.
But it is disruptive to
electrify and improve
an existing line.
You have to take
possession of the track.
You have to put people on
buses over bank holidays, all
of that.
The best argument for it, I
think, is to increase capacity.
Because if numbers carry
on going up and up,
then the existing
lines, eventually they
reach their limit.
However good the signalling,
however fast and long
and crammed the trains.
So to have an extra route, that
would be a very good thing.
And I think that's a better
argument than the accelerating
thing, because as a
lot of business people
said when they first
suggested we're
going to shave 15 minutes of
the journey to Birmingham,
well, now train
time is work time.
One of the themes
in railway history
is what you do
with all that time.
There was a great
explosion in reading
and publications and
things aimed specifically
at travelers.
And you can work.
And then of course, as
technology advances,
you can do almost
anything, really.
You can have your business
meeting on the train
through Wi-Fi.
Railways is a
difficult technology
to make all the remote
wireless technologies work.
I couldn't give you
chapter and verse,
but something about the
huge amounts of metal
moving at high speeds against
other huge amount of metal,
it's not just going
through the tunnels.
It's something
electro-magnetic going on.
So it will always be
difficult, I think.
And probably airlines
will be easier.
But that's the basic figures
for the travel, I think.
The time savings at
least for the first phase
are not so amazing as
we're sometimes told.
AUDIENCE: Which is your
favorite station in the UK?
SIMON BRADLEY: Ooh.
AUDIENCE: And why?
SIMON BRADLEY: That's tough.
I might go all sort of
wistful and say Ravenglass,
which is on the Cumbrian coast,
where we tend to have holidays.
But there's a change to a
narrow gauge railway, and almost
a miniature railway it's
called, because it's so small.
It's a sort of one-third
model of the national system.
It's worked mostly
by steam locomotives.
It goes right up into
the hills in the Fells.
And it's a proper piece
of public transport,
because there aren't
buses or anything.
So you get off the
train at Ravenglass,
and then there's this tiny
train waiting for you,
and it takes you five
miles up into the hills.
So yeah, I'd say Ravenglass.
AUDIENCE: That's good.
AUDIENCE: How inefficient
were steam trains compared
to the [INAUDIBLE] modern ones?
[INAUDIBLE] 10 pounds
for a five mile trip
on the [INAUDIBLE]
railway, and you
get to [INAUDIBLE] and
you pay seven pounds,
[INAUDIBLE] throughout
[INAUDIBLE].
How much of that is steam's
really, really expensive,
and how much of that is just
because [INAUDIBLE] huge costs?
SIMON BRADLEY: How
inefficient was steam?
It was massively, crippling,
staggeringly inefficient
is the answer.
When it's the only
way of doing anything,
yes, it's more efficient than
a horse, and a horse and cart.
But a great deal of the
coal burnt by the locomotive
just flies out of the chimney.
It doesn't burn
it as efficiently
as a power station does.
So that's one reason
why electrification
is more efficient
than steam, and why
they tried to electrify
as soon as they could
when they could afford it.
Other than that, they
spent a huge amount of time
just coming to the boil,
or having to be emptied
and cleaned out afterwards.
Because you can't just keep
them burning the whole time.
You have to make up the
fire, and then take fire out.
The water clogs the
boiler up with scale.
They've got huge numbers
of moving parts, which
require constant attention.
Where do you stop, really?
So and they were cheap to build.
That's the other thing.
They were much cheaper to build
than diesels or electrics.
So one of the wrong
turnings in railway history
after the Second World War
was to say, well, look.
Here we are.
We've got all this coal.
Oil is something
we have to import,
because there was no
North Sea oil then.
And electrification will do
it when we can afford it.
But in the meantime, we've got
lots more steam locomotives.
This is extraordinary.
The last steam locomotive
for the national system
for British Railways
was built in 1960.
And even then, they
thought it might have
a working life of 20 years.
And in 1955, they were
talking about steam maybe
lasting into the mid-1980s.
And that sounds weird until you
look at some other countries.
Because West Germany, as it
used to be before reunification,
which had a much more phased
program of modernization
and didn't have the mass
closures that we had,
the last steamhaul
passenger trains
in West Germany,
modern West Germany,
where all the modern stuff
comes from, ran in 1977.
So railway history is full
of surprises like that.
MALE SPEAKER: I've got one here.
AUDIENCE: So you said in
European [INAUDIBLE] railways
being continuously
rocked by innovation.
As a naive observer, it
looks like nothing much has
changed in the last 30 years.
Is that impression right?
Or has a lot of stuff changed?
SIMON BRADLEY: Has innovation
stopped on the railway?
Yeah, I don't think it has.
At the headline end, the British
Rail did have a research centre
at Darby.
It still goes on
doing bits and pieces,
but that was one of the
casualties of privatisation,
really.
And the railways had,
from innovation happening
in haphazard ways, like
Edmondson inventing
his tickets, the railways
to tried to harness it.
So there was a staff
college, and then
laboratories and things.
All that happens in the '30s.
So it has about a
50 year lifespan
of being at the core of what
the railways are trying to do.
But I think it's gone
massively international,
and that's part of it.
In this country, it's
suffered from privatisation,
because all the
uncertainties associated
with it, rather than necessarily
the private model in itself.
But track continues
to evolve and change.
The ways in which things
are done are more efficient.
And I think what isn't seen
quite so much is safety.
The critics within
the system say
the railways are now
too obsessed with safety
down to tiny little
imagined hazards,
little fences going up
at the ends of platforms.
For what?
To stop stray dogs or something?
Or to stop you walking off?
If you want to jump onto
a train, believe me.
You're going to do it.
But there's a lot of
spotting the possible hazard
thing going on.
It's quite expensive
to make those changes,
but the general
impetus is a good one.
I think it's eight years now
since a passenger or a worker
was killed on the railways.
Eight used to be about
the number of people
killed on the
railways every day.
That was when there were so
many men working on the tracks
coupling things up like
the people you see there.
Huge wagons are being
shunted up and down.
You've got to go between
them to couple them together.
The driver isn't paying
attention, or somebody's tired,
or somebody slips.
At the very least,
you might lose a limb.
So the railways used to
kill people all the time,
and now they don't.
So I think part of it
is about risk as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
SIMON BRADLEY: No.
I would have loved to
have seen it happen.
Sleeper trains are a
special private enthusiasm.
Do go on them if
you get a chance.
They're still there.
But what you can't do is
sleep under the tunnel.
You used to be able to do it
on something called the night
ferry, incidentally, that
left Victoria and was
pushed onto a train ferry and
taken off at the other end.
You would sleep
your way to Paris,
but that stopped in 1980.
But no, the answer is actually
it's a fall in air prices.
Air travel prices,
cheap flights,
the deregulation
of air travel, that
was what really wrecked
the business model.
But it was too late to stop
them from building lots and lots
of very high spec
sleeper carriages,
which were meant
to do just that.
You would have been able
to get on the train.
And it was very political.
You had to have direct services
from Wales and Scotland
as well as England.
You would be able to get
on the train in Glasgow,
and then you would dine as
you passed through England.
And then you'd go
under the tunnel,
and you'd wake up in
Berlin or something.
And they built these things.
But then the project was
cancelled before they'd even
turned a wheel in
actual service.
And these great white
elephant-- you can understand
there was a lot of
desire to hush this up,
because it was all
rather embarrassing.
And I excavated a bit of the
story in this John Prescott
rant to the House of Commons
in 1999 or something,
saying that I've
suddenly been asked
to come up with 200 million
for these carriages.
There's no use for them.
They don't work, and
they're sitting in a field,
or something like that.
But they did manage to sell
some of them to, I think,
the Canadian railways.
And now you can sleep your
way through the Rockies
or wherever the great Canadian
cross-continental journeys go.
But yeah, it was thought to
be the future with the Channel
Tunnel and the continuing
sleeper service.
And the answer is that,
yes, it's air competition.
Again, it's almost like
a miniature retread
of what British
railways got wrong
in the '50s of not plotting
the graph as to bigger lorries,
better lorries, motorways.
They didn't see
motorways coming.
So yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Time for
one more quick question.
There's a gentleman [INAUDIBLE].
Right here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
just wondering how
you feel the British
rail service compares
against the international
competitors.
Do you think the British people
are too harsh on rail service?
[INAUDIBLE] international
service to the EU
would be admired
significantly more
than what we have in the UK?
SIMON BRADLEY: Yes,
foreign comparisons.
I'm not the best
person to answer that,
partly because while I've
been working on this book,
I've been traveling
on the British railway
system for research
purposes in my spare time
rather than traveling
abroad so much.
But I think one
thing that is missed
is the density
density of traffic.
It's the number of fast
and efficient trains
that are running all the time.
It's the sheer numbers on
the move, the numbers going
in and out of Berlin, numbers
going in and out of Paris
by train, the numbers shuttling
back and forth between cities
abroad.
It just doesn't compare.
And it's always been like that.
The British steamhauled
railways had the highest number
of the fastest
trains in the world.
The special high speed
lines, that's shifting it.
But what we've only
got one of those,
and it only goes from London
to the Channel Tunnel.
So it's what's been achieved
on what's essentially a 19th
century route map, and
very often 19th century
infrastructure--- bridges,
viaducts, and things--
within the limits.
Because when they built the
Liverpool and Manchester
in 1830, the idea
that trains would ever
be electrified and travel
at 100 miles an hour,
and weigh 8 to 10 times as much,
and the whole thing not fall
apart, that would
have been mysterious.
If they'd had better ability
to calculate their risk factors
and loadings and
things, then they
wouldn't have built them
as sturdily as they did.
But they tended to err
on the side of caution.
So a Victorian railway viaduct,
Brunel's extraordinarily
elegant spare and an
amazingly flat bridge
across the Thames at Maidenhead
has carried the high speed
trains for years and years.
And now it's going to carry
the electric trains going even
faster, and it's still there.
Who'd have guessed it?
So I wouldn't say it's
doing the best of a bad job,
but really pushing the what
we've got to its limits.
Actually that should be a cause
for modest national pride,
perhaps.
MALE SPEAKER: Please
join me, and thank you.
Thank you so much.